Muy bien, tengo mi página web sobre conejos y
me gustaría editarla en mi editor de línea de
comando. Para hacer eso necesito ir
a mi línea de comando. En Windows,
pulso la tecla del logotipo de Windows
escribo 'cmd' y abre el símbolo del sistema.
Voy a usar eMacs que me permite editar
archivos planos, y ahora voy a escribir
un nombre de archivo. Digamos que es todo
sobre conejos punto html. Presiono Enter y
ahora estoy dentro del editor, aquí pego
el código que copié y ahora puedes ver
que mi html está dentro de eMacs y puedo
modificarlo directamente. Y, si quisiera,
puedo hacer una pequeña edición aquí, y luego
voy a guardar pulsando este icono. Muy bien,
ya lo guardé, y ahora voy a abrirlo escribiendo
directamente el nombre del archivo en la línea
de comando y dando Enter. Con esto se abre
el archivo en el navegador, ahí lo vemos. Y,
si quiero, puedo abrirlo nuevamente y hacer
algunos cambios y luego volver a cargar la página
cuando haya terminado. Vamos a agregar más signos
de exclamación en el título. Lo guardo, regreso al
navegador lo actualizo y, ¡ta-dá!, ahí lo tienes.
Este es el flujo de trabajo de la línea de comando
y será diferente dependiendo de qué editor de
línea de comando usemos, pero generalmente se
trata de usar muchos comandos diferentes,
sentirse realmente cómodo con este editor,
y encontrar un buen flujo para editar
y volver a cargar en el navegador.